this week we've teamed up with our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go to erasable pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show and we are taking
some of the burden off Santa's Shoulders
by answering some of the handwritten
letters sent his
[Music]
way hi my name is Ja I'm 6 years old
I've been helping my friends and family
at home and in school I have a big
collection of Godzillas so sad
can you please get me St Godzilla I want
St Godzilla the present to be under my
trees my name is Emma I'm 6 years old I
have to walk everywhere cuz it's such a
pain so I really love T Hanah for a
hoverboard so I can glide in the
Christmas Merry Christmas hi I'm why I'm
5 years old hi I'm wday I'm 7 years old
we're brothers Dear Santa for Christmas
I want a 100 sports cars a cotton candy
machine and a picture of Rudolph so I
can see if he's real I like a baby
cheetah because it's fast and the
biggest pizza in the world so I can eat
it with my friends thank you s the love
W hi I'm Henry I'm 8 years old hi I'm
Charlie I'm 5 years old they call me
Charlie and Charli
what I really want for Christmas is a
real Harry Potter one to turn my baby
brother Teddy into
Yoda I would like an accordion that is
just like weird out and it's perfect it
has rainbow sparkles and it's
footle bye Santa than by Santa thank you
my name's Andrea my name's Grace my
name's we're all triplet 46y old old hi
my name is Thomas and I am 9 years old
for Christmas I want mini Brands because
I have a whole collection of them for
Christmas I want a unicorn for Christmas
I want tickets to the Olympics me too I
go oh boy All I Want for Christmas Is
some peace and quiet we want to
celebrate kiddos like you creating
fearless and bold holiday letters so we
are giving you $1,000
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home